the first major challenge for social
distancing regulations as Americans
venture out for Memorial Day weekend the
unofficial start of summer kicks off
with restrictions loosened in all 50
states the u.s. death toll from the
coronavirus says top 96 thousand now
there have been more than 1.6 million
cases reported of the virus in the
country this is President Trump makes
the case for houses of worship to reopen
this weekend places that he describes as
essential operations at the same time
air travel is down 88 percent this
weekend compared to last year's Memorial
Day weekend some Americans are planning
to get out and enjoy the nice weather
long lines of cars were spotted Friday
along Florida's Gulf Coast but this is
going to look different this summer the
beach will have a slightly different
feel a much different feel Michael
George begins our coverage from New
York's Coney Island Michael good morning
good morning Jeff it's a foggy rainy
morning here on the Coney Island
boardwalk but the weather is expected to
clear up for Memorial Day and many see
this weekend as a test for Americans can
people enjoy the holiday weekend safely
at beaches across the nation Memorial
Day weekend will show signs of a
pandemic in progress
no coolers umbrellas or group sports
will be allowed at Los Angeles beaches
if we need to put up fencing we will New
York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio has
positioned fencing near beaches to be
used for crowd control there beachgoers
can't swim or participate in group
activities and on lake michigan
restrooms will be closed we just need
people to come prepared know wherever
they do choose to go make sure you know
what those restrictions are and just be
prepared for those an inconvenience in
the making according to Nakia Gordon I
mean I get all the way down here and I
mean if you have kids or something you
know you really have to I mean you can't
plan that as of yesterday every coastal
state except Massachusetts Rhode Island
and New Hampshire opened some Shores
many with take-it-or-leave-it
restrictions go outside and take in
fresh air breathe in and breathe out
recharge but do it respond
simply do it safely Indiana governor
Eric whole combs call for safety will be
poolside as the Forest Hill community
pool opens for the weekend complete with
a new 45 person limit and sanitized
beach chairs we're putting our trust in
the actual members and we're hoping that
everybody will abide by the rules but
Memorial Day weekend 2020 also arrives
after a week where there were more than
a hundred and fifty thousand new known
cases more than eight thousand deaths in
the US and some persistent unknowns
there may be a lot of people under 30
the have the virus and are shedding the
virus and aren't aware that they have
the virus dr. deborah birx coordinator
of the White House coronavirus task
force and so proactive monitoring
proactive testing will become absolutely
critical to find these asymptomatic
cases concern about a second wave of
infections from opening too much too
soon may have borne out in Montgomery
County Alabama with a number of positive
coronavirus cases more than doubled in
the last two weeks after stay at home
orders eased I think we reopened our
economy too soon and I think that people
did not adhere to some of the social
distancing guidelines and as the country
begins to reopen the travel industry saw
another casualty car rental giant Hertz
filed for bankruptcy facing billions of
dollars in debt
Michelle wow Michael thank you